عاصفه عقوبات غربيه اذا على مسؤولينا
وكيانات في ايران طال بعضها مؤسسه تتبعون
الحرس الثوري لكن حزمه العقوبات الاوروبيه
طغى عليها خلافا بشان استهداف الحرس
الثوري اما واشنطن فلم تتوانى عن استهدافي
مؤسسه تابعه للحرس الثوري ونائب مدير
الاستخبارات في لندن لم يختلف المشهد
عقوبات على مسؤولين ايرانيين وعلى راسهم
المدعي العام وفي طهران لم يبدا الامر
مفاجئا في ظل الاعتياد على العقوبات لكنه
وزير الخارجيه توعد بلد قويا اذا استهدفت
مؤسسات تونسيه مثل الحرس الثوري
اذا قالت الرئاسه السويديه للاتحاد
الاوروبي ان وزراء خارجيه الاتحاد اقروا
حزمه جديده من العقوبات على ايران واضافت
في تغريده على تويتر ان العقوبات على
ايران تستهدفه من يقودون القمع على حد
تعبيرها واوضحت الرئاسه السويديه ان
الاتحاد الاوروبيه يدين بقوه ما سمتها
الاستخدام الوحشيه وغير المتناسب للقوه من
جانب السلطات الايرانيه في مواجهه
المتظاهرين السلبيين وقالت مصادر لرويترز
انه وزراء خارجيه التكتل سيضفون سبعه
وثلاثين اسما لقائمه الاتحاد الاوروبي
للافرادي والكيانات الخاضعين لعقوبات بسبب
انتهاكات حقوق الانسان في ايران
هذا وقد قال بيان الاوروبيون العقوبات
الجديده ضد الافراد والكيانات الايرانيه
تشمل تجميد الاصول وحضر السفر الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي وحضر اتاحت الاموال من هم مدرجون
في القائمه كما تم فرد حظر على تصدير
المعدات الى ايران والتي يمكن استخدامها
للقمع الداخلي ومعدات مراقبه الاتصالات
وحتى الاتحاد الاوروبي السلطات الايرانيه
على وقت ما وصفها بحمله القمع العنيفه ضد
الاحتجاجات السلميه
هذا مقاله مفاوض السياسات الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بورال ان اراء
اعضاء الاتحاد متباينه بشان وضع الحرس
الثوري الايراني على قائمه العقوبات
الاوروبيه وانه يجب دراسه الامر قبل اتخاذ
قرار مجرا الى انه لا يمكن تصنيف الحرس
الثوري منظمه ارهابيه من دون حكم قضائي
المتباينه
لكن لا يمكن اتخاذ قرار دون حكم محكمه
عندما تاخذ محكمه في احدى الدول الاعضاء
قرارا بشان ذلك وتظهر ادانه واضحه حينها
يمكننا العمل على المستوى الاوروبي لكن
قبل هذا كله كما قلت يتطلب الامر حكم
القضائيا
وفي واشنطن اعلنت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه
عقوبات شملت المؤسسه التعاونيه للحرس
الثوري الايراني وخمسه اعضاء من مجلس
ادارتها بالاضافه الى نائب وزير
الاستخبارات والامن واربعه من كبار قاده
الحرس الثوري في ايران وافادت الوزاره في
بيان ان الاجراء الذي تم بالتنسيق مع
بريطانيا والاتحاد الاوروبي يستهدفوا
ركيزه اقتصاديه رئيسيه للحرس الثوري
الايراني معتبره انها تمول من القمع
الوحشي للاحتجاجات على حديث عبير البيان
وقال مساعد وزيره الخزانه ان بلاده تضل
ملتزيمه بدعم الشعب الايراني في تظلم
ملتزمه في دعم الشعب الايراني في مقاله
بحقوق الانسان والحريات الاساسيه مشددا
على انها ستواصل العمل مع شركائها لمحاسبه
النظام الايرانيه على العنف والمحاكمات
السواريه واعدام المتظاه واساليب القمع
الاخرى حسب نص البيان
هذا هو اعلنت بريطانيا اليوم وحزمه جديده
من العقوبات على مسؤولين ايرانيين ونددت
بما سمته العنف الذي تمارسها السلطات
البلاد ضد شعبها بما في ذلك اعدام المواطن
البريطانيه الايراني علي رضا اكبري وتشمل
العقوبه البريطانيه الجديده تجميد اصول
وحذره على عدد من المسؤولين بمنفيهم
نائبوا المدعي العام الايراني احمد فضل
وزير الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس كليفر لي في
بيان ان من صدرت عقوبات بحقهم اليوم
شخصيات قضائيه تستغل عقوبه الاعدام لاغراض
سياسيه وافراد عصابه يعتدون بالضرب على
المحتاجين في الشوارع